Gavin Newsom who I truly believe is an
evil lizard person from another planet
oh my God uh he went on Sean Hannity and
just laid out a whole bunch of bunk
which we'll debunk in just a sec but
here's his bunk
in 2021 California 7.8 percent of GDP
GDP growth in this country one of the
fastest growing economies anywhere on
planet Earth this state continues to be
the Temple of the American economy 25.6
percent of All American jobs came from
this state in April and the last two
fiscal years we enjoyed
177.7 billion dollars in operating
surpluses we're on our way to be the
fourth largest economy Eat Your Heart
Out Germany in the world number one in r
d Venture Capital more scientists
researchers more Nobel laureates more
patents emanating out of this state than
any other state in America with all due
respect Florida doesn't even come close
Eat Your Heart Out Texas California
continues to be dominant economic engine
for them I promised you before this
interview I would let you give full
answers that's a full answer thank you
okay so almost everything he said there
was either a lie or a confusion in terms
of some of the numbers California
despite the 1.5-ish million people who
fled is still a massive state so a lot
of their numbers seem very big but it's
purely because yes for decades it was
the place every wanted to everyone want
to go now it's the place that everyone
wants to flee uh Miriam the craziness
there people always say Well when is it
going to stop or or what is the low
Point what is what is the bottom so that
they can reverse it I see no reversal on
this thing I I think they are just going
off the deep end what do you think well
absolutely and and he just it's like he
just doesn't see what's happening right
in front of his very eyes in places like
San Francisco which is just absolutely
falling apart and he doesn't recognize
or he refuses to admit all the people
that have fled California they're
hightailing out of there with good
reason and so I don't know how he can
you know it's fine he can memorize all
of his little stats and pretend that
they are creating this this narrative
that's utterly untrue to anyone who has
actual eyes and ears on the ground but
but you know it's clearly false and you
only need to look at the actual things
that are happening he talks in circles
that's what he's doing he's talking it's
like I can smell him through the screen
it's like he smells like bad colors
it's so gross I mean he smells like a
used car salesman with way too much
cologne on he's just like he he's a
complete scheme I know we're supposed to
be talking about data and stuff like
that but that's he's like the cult of
personality to me like he is the guy
that like he's the empty suit he says a
bunch of words they mean nothing people
buy into that crap but I do want to read
you guys a couple stats that actually
will give a little more context than
what he was tossing out there this is
from the public policy Institute of
California California's violent crime
rate increased by six percent from 440
to per 100 000 residents in 2020 to 466
in 2021 while robberies fell somewhat by
1.9 percent aggravated assaults jump
Point by uh 8.9 percent and homicides
and rape those are the really bad ones
increased by 7.7 and 7.9 percent uh
respectively and let's just do a little
bit more here this is from California
matters uh the first Statewide snapshot
of California's homelessness crisis
since the pandemic hit reveals that the
number of people without a stable place
to call home increased by at least 22
500 people over the past three years to
a hundred seventy three thousand eight
hundred homelessness grew by 15 this is
from governing.com for all of 2022
California's economy ranked 10th worst
for GDP growth among the states
advancing only point four percent versus
a 2.1 percent National Pace top growth
was found in Idaho at 4.9 percent then
Tennessee at 4-3 Florida at 4 percent
Nevada at 3 7 and Texas at 3.4 percent
so that is really the proof in the
pudding stuff that in the last two years
basically as we have lived through all
of this craziness where are people
moving Idaho Tennessee Texas Florida
anywhere else literally anywhere else
yeah